good evening thank you all for coming
out it's great to see you I'm Alexander
Rose I'm the executive director at the
long now foundation and as you know
before these talks we show what's called
a long short a short film that
exemplifies long term thinking the long
short that we have this evening is by
Jason Taylor and I'm actually going to
let it speak for itself for the most
part and just say a couple words at the
end but one note about it so a couple of
one of the pieces that you will see in
it is is called what have we done
[Music]
you
you
Jason Taylor generously allowed us to
that and it's as you saw it was kind of
a time-lapse of the first year in
existence of a artificial reef project
he was he did instead of just putting
concrete tubes down at the bottom of the
the water he put down those sculptures
which he then filmed over several years
and they've also been designed as a
tourist attraction so you can go dive
there and Grenada and Cancun and go
check those out and see how they're
evolving as well thanks Alexander I'm
Stuart brand from the long now
foundation no pulling here Timothy
Ferriss has written two books for our
workweek and for our body
how many have written or ever read one
of those books how many both of those
books it looks like about a fifth of the
audience good it's gonna be a lot of
news here I used to know a name Gregory
Bateson as an anthropologist biologist
epistemologists was married to Margaret
Mead for an interesting while and it was
one of the first people who worked with
dolphins dolphin communication dolphin
learning things like that they were
working in Hawaii and he was part of the
dolphin sort of parked there so they
were doing behavioral training as well
as behavioral study of how these
dolphins did things there was one really
smart female dolphin they were working
with one day and the deal was that the
dolphin would be let out of the holding
tank into the performance area and what
they wanted from her was new tricks and
so she would go around and do random
things and do whatever was done before
but she wouldn't get the reward of a
fish for doing what was done before they
were waiting for a new trick and this
one the session she came out she did the
previous trick she done the previous
trick before that no fish finally she
did something new and she got the fish
and she got really excited now she was
supposed to take a break so they took
her off to the holding tank again and
five minutes went by and they brought
her back in
go through that process again she was
completely excited swinging around and
before they could stop her she they did
she did 20 new tricks that nobody had
ever seen before
and she had gone from learning in
Gregory's view to what he called meta
learning she had learned about learning
so we have an exceptionally skillful
fish dolphin for you tonight you're the
fish he's the dolphin Timothy Ferriss
[Applause]
good evening this is a big auditorium
thanks for coming
I hope to live up to my my dolphin kin
very very cool video if you have a
chance to watch dolphins in front of
mirrors they're one of the few animals
that actually the self-awareness to
recognize themselves in a mirror
accelerated learning meta skills skills
we all have skills to learn we have
things to learn and in the firehose of
information that is the digital age it
will be increasingly important certainly
if you want to scale your life scale
your career scale your enjoyment of life
and this is the subject of today's talk
it is the first time that I'm giving
this particular presentation so if it's
a little choppy please bear with me we
will have plenty of time for Q&A which
I'm very much looking forward to and I
apologize for not having time for
signing any books but I will make it up
to you guys and I'm already noodling on
how to do that so thank you all for
coming and without further ado let's
jump right into it
so the contrarian ethos my good man Mark
Twain's whenever you find yourself in
the side of majority it's time to pause
and reflect so seldom is the most common
way of doing something or the best
practice actually the best way to go
about learning it performing it
excelling at it and that is what I'd
like you to return to is your refrain as
we look at the different examples that
I'll put forth this odd-looking molecule
here is actually a peptide hormone and
it is vasopressin perhaps I should say
desmopressin because that's the
synthetic version of vasopressin which
is an antidiuretic hormone and my
interest in learning started at the
biochemical level really when I started
digging into it and so I used to use and
I don't suggest this of course I would
never suggest such a thing
I used to use antidiuretic hormone as a
nasal spray which is typically used for
bedwetting children actually but it has
some spectacular effects on short-term
memory so I would take two sniffs one in
each nostril prior to Chinese character
quizzes
and it was phenomenally effective but I
decided you know maybe snorting
antidiuretic hormone not the best
long-term strategy so I started to do a
bit more analysis looking at more
structured methodical approaches to
learning and for me when people ask me
what is your goal in life what is
success to you I've thought about it
quite a lot because I get asked so
frequently and my answer is to love be
loved and to never stop learning so the
learning is very very key to me what
you're looking at right here is the
jewel congi hill and these are in this
particular case 1945 common use
characters in the Japanese language I
bought this at age 15 it since been
increased the number of characters but
1945 this to me encapsulated the
Japanese language and became my target
for my first year abroad my first really
extended trip overseas at all which was
in Japan going from Long Island to Japan
was quite a culture shock but I did
ultimately nail this list and as a
result was able to speak read write
Japanese and if you've studied in
languages perhaps you have avoided
studying languages you have certainly
heard a few things number one is that
children learn languages faster than
adults
I think it's complete nonsense
personally if you've ever talked to a
three-year-old like how good is that
English not very good it's really not
too impressive spend three years
studying a language you should be better
than that
there is a great book called in other
words one of the co-authors is hakuta h
aku ta which i think underscores the
fact that as an adult you have a
framework you have existing knowledge to
hang that language that new language and
you can learn much much faster secondly
to really master language it'll take
your entire life also in my experience
complete nonsense I think that anywhere
from 2 months to 12 months more than
sufficient to become functionally fluent
in any language that I've encountered so
far which would include Chinese Japanese
Gaelic Irish probably the hardest I've
bumped into because no one speaks in the
list goes on and on and on so it's worth
testing the assumptions it's worth
testing the common knowledge that you
hear so the guiding process and I'm
going to use a lot of examples from
language learning because I think it's
so intimidating for people but we're
also going to look at physical skills so
not only the declarative knowledge the
data but the procedural the actual
movement sports etc so the guiding
process so Diesel's face what the hell
does that mean the way you can remember
this entire process is imagining Vin
Diesel space grimacing at you like
excruciating detail right up in your mug
all right so what this means is d is for
deconstruction identifying the minimal
discrete usable units in whatever this
subject is that you're trying to master
and when I say master typically I mean
you're in the upper 5% so the 95 plus
percent selection is allow the Jo kanji
what can I eliminate to get to the 20%
that will yield me 80 plus percent of
the output so very classic Pareto 80/20
analysis but what what is the minimal
effective dose and we'll come back to
that sequencing whether it's in golf
grammar swimming technique will look at
swimming how do you then take those
Pareto identified units and sequence
them in the right fashion this is where
most people make the biggest mistakes is
in the sequencing and then the
latter three are separated out because
they're particularly important for
anything specifically mental but we have
frequency and we'll come to that whether
it's exercise or memorization how do you
space things out compression and that is
how do you compress what you need to
know into some type of holistic buts but
very graspable unit like one page I'll
give examples of that and then last
encoding mnemonics how do you actually
memorize this stuff and how do you
recall it so this is a lot I'm gonna
give a handful of examples it's going to
be a bit like wandering through the mind
of a madman hopefully it'll make sense
if not we'll hit it in the Q&A but then
diesel in your face alright so
deconstruction anomalies and extremes
the deconstruction for me starts with
looking for anomalies and extremes what
I mean by that is if I'm trying to
identify a skill and then learn that
skill I want to find the people who are
good at it despite not being built for
it this would be one such example so
here you have a supposedly normal high
school girl 134 pounds who just so
happens to deadlift 405 pounds for
repetitions off the floor without any
wraps of any type
she's a sprinter and so the deadlift for
people who are not familiar with it is
sumo deadlift at least barbell plates
come down and then you pick it up like
so so she can do that with 405 pounds
for repetitions and she looks completely
normal
another example of this would be Brian
Mackenzie Brian Mackenzie was in the
4-hour body because he is able to train
people for 50 100-mile races while
having them run no longer than 10
kilometers 10 miles in a giving training
cycle 8 weeks from ground zero
no running experience to running let's
say a mountainous 50 kilometer or 50
mile race so I'm looking for not only
the people who are best at what they do
let's say a Scott Jurek who's six foot
two hundred and forty pounds built like
a spider he's perfect for let's say the
western states 100 race but I'll use him
by asking who are the people who are
good at this who shouldn't
finding the anomalies and then asking a
few simple questions are you the only
one have you replicated this could you
train someone to do this and my
recommendation for seeking those people
out is don't go for the person who's
currently in the limelight so let's just
say it's New York Times bestselling
authors and you want to learn about
publishing well don't go after the
people who are currently on the list go
after the people who might be crying
crocodile tears like me in a few years
who are let's say on the list two years
ago and they will be in many cases very
easy to find and the fastest route for
that is going through a personal blog
even if they have a very very high
trafficked group blog look for their
personal blog so this is what I was able
to do after trying to replicate this
anomaly that I showed you in the
previous slide this is that mission
cliffs right here in San Francisco in
Harrison it's a rock climbing gym I
actually go there because it's one of
the few places let me lets me use chalk
or lifting away
[Music]
[Applause]
watch the dramatic breathing going on
okay all right so what I said there's no
wraps what I want to underscore here is
that I went from having a maximum
because I have weep
I've weak grip I went from having a
maximum deadlift of about 300 - that was
about 585 and I got up to between 650
and 700 that's with a double overhand
grip like this that's the weakest grip
you can possibly use it's not
alternating it's not a hook grip with
the thumbs it's not strapped double
overhand grip just like so and that was
done in about eight weeks and the dose
so to speak was two or three sessions
per week about five minutes of total
muscular tension per week that's it
and the discrete unit all right looking
at the deconstruction was a segment of
the lift so what if we did the opposite
of best practice and I want to share
with you the questions that I asked
myself because I think the questions are
oftentimes more important than the
answer you have to ask the right
questions and this is one of the right
questions so when people train the
deadlift there are a few things that
they do and quite often the advice that
you'll receive is you should do rack
pulls meaning in your strongest range of
motion you should pull from here to here
which is what I demonstrated the way I
trained for that was in fact doing two
or three repetitions in my weakest range
of motion from the floor to about here
one two sets done that's all I did
all right so I did exactly the opposite
of what most people would recommend
looking at discrete units on the mental
side this is a very popular character
this is the character for love in
Japanese or Chinese depends on which
which which type of Chinese were talking
about so it's fine the traditional this
is I in so I sort of Japanese to love
and what I've identified here are three
radicals and you could look at let's say
1945 characters and become overwhelmed
in Chinese it's much much worse well you
could look at 1945 in oh my god how am I
ever gonna possibly learn this many
characters but if you chunk it down you
realize that each of those characters is
made up of some combination of 217
radicals all right so you have at the
very top something called come buddy
which is like a crown so you could say
that's a claw going through a roof
number 2 is a heart and then number 3 is
to go or to go slowly so you can imagine
sort of clawing your way through a roof
to get at a heart that's running away
that's love it's very endearing I think
that's how you would then form the
visual Association to remember this
character I wish it were that easy for
all characters it isn't but when you
develop a facility for this you can
memorize characters very very quickly
the only way you achieve that
efficiently and effectively is by
breaking it down to these discrete units
the extremes are also I think very very
helpful when you're looking at
scientific inquiry when you're looking
at clinical studies there's a lot of
emphasis placed on the median the mode
averages of different types this can be
helpful but it can be also very very
misleading not terribly instructional so
if you look on the left hand side here
you see a pair of garden shears and if
you haven't seen objectified I would
recommend you see all the films done by
a filmmaker but there was an interview
with frog design also in this area and
they were giving a hypothetical example
of a client coming in and saying well we
have these garden shears we want you to
make a new version and our average user
is middle-aged woman of this type this
height the set and they said we don't
care about your average user we want to
know about the extremes we want to know
about the paraplegic who has these
following limitations we also want to
know about the 300-pound bodybuilder
can't brush his teeth because it's
biceps are too big once we solve for
those two situations everything in
between takes care of itself and for
that reason I explore the fringes I look
for the outliers and that could mean any
number of things it could mean flying
stem cell growth fact
from Israel combining it with my own
platelet-rich plasma and igf-1 and other
things and injecting it up and down my
spine only to realize that you know what
the best option is somewhere in-between
where I'm just using Prolotherapy
basically sugar water to address a lot
of my pre-existing injuries
it could also mean pushing it as far as
I can with with memory both recognition
and recall so there is a a an author
named dr. Greenberg grun eb ERG who has
written a number of books using the
linked word method so french by
association spanish by association
visual images combined with the
vocabulary items and so i have
experimented with these books and
crammed for 350 to 807 day now if you
consider that the functional vocabulary
you need to really sound fluent in most
situations is I would say around 1200
words so that means two days of vocab
and I was able to reach about 85% recall
doing that with Spanish at least and you
realize what works what doesn't and
what's scaleable very quickly when you
explore some of the fringes
all right selection all right so D so
selection the minimum effective dose so
this is the 80/20 analysis that I was
referring to earlier so whether you are
looking at physical exercise whether you
are looking at memorization I encourage
you to look at the methods just like you
would look at a drug antibiotic the
right dose gets you what you want to
little won't achieve the effect you
desire too much will produce side
effects whether that's overtraining
whether that's some type of insomnia
there are all sorts of side effects that
come with learning things if you take it
too far
in the wrong direction two examples here
if Tracy Rifkin she lost about 120
pounds doing kettlebell swings two or
three times per week and I've since then
refined that and further reduced it down
to five minutes three times a week of
kettlebell swings so one set three times
a week
she lost 120 pounds and thus far since
the 4-hour body came out in December
we've had many people lose more than
hundred pounds since December
mid-december
which is amazing on the right hand side
this is just protein and I'll give a
very clear example of why that's there
so we already talked about the five
minutes of kettlebell swings three times
per week the sample minimum effective
dose 30 grams of protein within 30
minutes of waking up this one change
when my dad implemented this took his
monthly fat loss from 5 pounds per month
to 18.75 in the first month so if you
want to lose body fat very simple take
60 seconds with whey protein to do that
90 to 120 seconds of tension so this is
one set to failure for most muscles once
per week you're done and then moving out
of the physical realm 20,000 early
evangelists that's a term on borrowing
from Eric Ries in two weeks for the New
York Times best seller list
alright so targeting the right fans so
one thousand true fans one of my
favorite pieces ever encourage you all
to read it kevin kelly but if you hit
10,000 sales per week for two weeks
straight which allows you to hopefully
dodge any dark horses or incumbents
you've a very good chance hitting the
other times and you need that precise
number to make intelligent decisions
lastly 1200 words for conversational
fluency in most languages so these are
the type of very precise minimum
effective doses allow you to select what
it is you're going to focus on
sequencing how do you put all this stuff
in order well it's very helpful to work
from the most fundamental obviously to
the more complicated but something like
grammar I think it's it's fairly
straightforward but let's look at
swimming
so in swimming in golf also just read an
interview today in fact with a
professional golfer who said people code
me and they say I have trouble with my
backswing
I've trouble with my putt and I look at
their backswing other putt it's fine
it's just that they had the sequence
they had the movement out of order so
their shoulder moves before the hip or
there's some type of sequencing issue
timing issue this was swimming for those
of you don't know I was unable to swim
until about age 31 32 couldn't swim at
all
I was born premature problems with the
left lung could not swim I was phobic
even having grown up on the beach I
could play in the waves and so forth but
lapse forget about it at a max of maybe
two laps harpy would go to 200 plus
within a week of looking at the
sequencing and testing some of the
assumptions all
all these are interrelated I was able to
get up to you between 20 and 30 laps per
session alright a couple of things I
want you to know this is Terry Laughlin
who is the founder of Total Immersion
swimming first I want you to notice he's
that fuselage and left all right so
these on this gliding left position and
notice how far below the surface of the
water his left hand is he's not reaching
out and then pulling is actually
focusing more on the driving and one of
the ways if you want to talk about going
against best practices one of the ways
that Total Immersion has you trained is
by doing freestyle with fists so you're
not allowed to use your hands you
actually have to make fists with both
hands and then swim you should try it
people will think you're crazy but you
test these assumptions the other was
kicking so first thing that happens
typically to people when they want to
learn how to swim is you have some
extremely accomplished swimmer say
here's a cake board go do 20 laps and I
would just thrash like a drowning monkey
that wouldn't move and is very
frustrated that would quit there's very
little kicking in total immersion so I
want you to look at the sequence here
very slight kick with that leg and the
only purpose is to rotate the hips and
what Terry is aiming to do is spend its
much time possible in a fuselage left
fuselage right
alright and notice where his hand enters
the water is right by his head and then
streamline right alright so sequencing
very very important I will come back to
a language example frequency it's a
frequency is a big big topic and there's
a lot of time spent researching it a big
house forget it for getting curves there
are many many tools that can be used on
key is one for iPhone which is I think
quite interesting which means rote
memorization in Japanese as a side note
super memo has become very famous on
some level because of wired coverage
primarily so super memo also if you want
to try to space things out in a Pimsleur
like approach I would recommend looking
at that I think frequency is arguably
the least important piece of the entire
puzzle and that's controversial I think
that stance but in my experience if you
for example associate properly you use
your existing knowledge base and build
scaffolding on that to learn whatever
target you have you can get away with
one exposure if you do it properly very
very frequently but I will give you one
perhaps slightly unusual example of
frequency and that is Tim Ferriss before
and after antigravity shorts are
optional
I gained 34 pounds of fat free mass in
28 days and total amount of gym time was
30 minutes twice per weeks in this case
it was literally the 4-hour body on a
monthly basis
that's when eating becomes your job but
the the minimum effective dose the
necessary frequency for this for
language learning is much less than
people realize what I would suggest for
languages again focusing on that because
it can be so intimidating for people is
rather than taking classes for a year
doing them twice per week and then going
to Italy let's just say to practice your
Italian I would suggest saving that
money going a week early and just
cramming for seven days straight eight
nine 10 hours a day and I think your
results would be better perfect nine
times out of ten as a starter kit if
you're focusing on Spanish German there
are a few others and you can get a
Michelle Thomas DVD set mich al th o mas
that are actually performed by Michelle
Thomas a fantastic language learner I
would suggest you start there that's all
we're gonna say about frequency we can
certainly talk about it more but I don't
think it's the the most important or
neglected piece of the puzzle
compression this is very important I
think psychologically to provide a
feedback loop a positive feedback loop
language in particular can be very very
overwhelming there are many subjects
whether that language be a natural
language a computer language certainly
natural language to be very overwhelming
the daunting task of tackling something
that seems to have no end so this is
what I would call the eight cents audit
and when I am diving into a new language
I've done this with at least 12
languages and coincidentally started off
thinking I was bad at languages just to
make that really clear it wasn't until
sophomore year in high school and I
transferred from public school on Long
Island to a private school in New
Hampshire when I took Japanese and had a
very good teacher and ended up learning
Japanese well enough that I could go
abroad as an exchange student prior to
that I had assumed because I could not
learn Spanish or so I thought that I was
bad at languages so just just to offer
that as some context so the Apple is red
it is John's Apple I give John the Apple
what I will do with the native speaker
and it's important that you know how to
train native speakers to teach you if
you let's say form an agreement with a
native speaker of language X and you're
like let's go hang out I'll teach you
English you teach me Spanish that will
never work it never works saying I could
point to somebody in the audience
respect what's the difference between
something in anything and just let your
ramble for a few minutes we cannot
explain our own native language is
really really hard to do so the way you
get around that is by asking a handful
of questions and I always start with can
you help me translate these sentences
know why these sentences there are a few
things you'll notice right off the bat
what you will identify first and
foremost is the language
subject-object-verb
as Japanese would be is it
subject-verb-object
I eat the Apple as English would be
Mandarin Chinese as well and then you
start to notice tiny little tweaks they
also give you an indication of how hard
the language will be to learn so if you
want to choose a language and you want
to choose carefully so that you're not
spinning your wheels
you'll also notice things like noun
cases so alright the Apple is red I give
John the Apple that's accusative case so
if any of you speak any German if you
play around with any Russian god forbid
you will recognize that these these
change very very quickly all right
you'll also notice how indirect and
direct objects are used all right so if
you want to say nominal right give it to
me and span
if you wanted to use then say in that
particular case and how likely and say
and interchange all of these things you
can learn from these eight sentences and
as soon as you tagged a question mark on
to the end of one of these or you make
it a negative so she doesn't give it to
him you can very quickly figure out for
example if it that's a separate word as
it would be in Chinese like Pabu nan Chu
I can't go or if in in Japanese if it's
a declension if you actually have to
conjugate so and also Quinny a key and i
like he can't go there or she there's no
he she i you and that particular
sentence if it's a declension if it's
conjugation you know it's gonna be
harder to learn all right at the very
bottom i want to point out two things
specific language learning I must give
it to him I want to give it to her all
right I must I want I need these are
auxiliary verbs so if you want to cheat
and give yourself a lot of positive
feedback really really early on let's
just take Spanish as an example that's
fantastic you just learn how to
conjugate get it to want I you can this
you thought you conjugate three or four
of these verbs and that automatically
gives you access to every single verb in
the language because you just take the
infinitive of that verb and you throw it
at the end it's a really really useful
cheat and what you find also let's say
in Spanish or in a tie and a lot of
Romance languages is you could say I'm
trying to think of the Italian version
who speaks Italian here anybody know
sometimes okay okay so you can say like
oh diamond ticket all right like what
the Amenti got to do okay so the
mantecato I forgot I have forgotten once
you learn that in Spanish would be a bet
you learn that conjugation then you can
cheat any past tense all right it's
fantastic so learning the auxiliary
verbs gives you this minimum effective
dose to use any verb and if you focus on
let's say the first person second person
singular you're set to really
communicate in a native language that's
it so what I mean by the eighth sentence
on it is I have compressed the majority
of the language into one sheet
and you can do that also with let's say
an essay or a self introduction you
translate a self introduction on one
piece of paper and all of a sudden you
can learn just about every verb form in
let's say the German language and use
that as your cheats use so whenever you
feel overwhelmed you go back to that one
sheet here are a few real-world examples
these are all from airplanes so god
forbid you get stuck next to me on an
airplane and you speak some language
that I don't speak this is what happens
so you have the top left that's Arabic I
was on a trip was not to an
arabic-speaking country but I just went
kind of crazy on Arabic and then on the
right-hand side this is Russian so I got
really into Russian you can see you know
I give the Apple to him I eat the apple
and these things are actually what I use
this is Cyrillic on the left hand side
on the bottom left and then 20 minutes
later I'm reading a printout of a
Russian article alongside a Ukrainian
woman who was teaching me through like
and the highlights are what I messed up
that's it 20 minutes later and that is
not a testament to what I can memorize
its testament to asking the right
questions and running through this type
of deconstruction with let's say eight
sentences it's very simple but it works
very well alright in coding we're gonna
have plenty of time for Q&A don't worry
so in coding I want to talk about what's
involved with memorization so I think
memorization is a very nebulous term it
doesn't need to be but there are
different ways to memorize so the I want
to give a few primary methods and
contrast them and talk about the the
right way and what I would consider the
wrong or very an effective way to go
about memorizing let's say foreign
language of vocabulary has anyone heard
of the loci method I'm sure there's
somebody in there has so locus is
singular for location or place in Latin
loci would be multiple places and this
is also called the mental walk method of
memorization it was very widely used in
the Senate in Rome
Cicero used this so if you were if you
if he were
speaking to an audience like this he
would take his talking points and make
mental images that he would place around
the room and he would go from point to
point
using these visual cues in his mind to
remind him of his topics and you can do
this in a physical location but you can
also use a very well-traveled route that
you know by heart and you can use this
to great effect this can be combined
with what is called the consonant system
the phonetic system Dominic O'Brien is
world champion and some of these memory
competitions also the Dominic method
what the constant method does is it
converts numbers into consonants so for
example seventy one seven would be a K
or a cus on and then I because it has a
single down stroke as T or D so that
could be cat it could be caught I'll
explain why one is better than the other
in a moment and using that method even
if you are bad at remembering numbers
and I consider myself intrinsically very
very poor at memorizing numbers well
once you practice the consonant system
Dominic uses actual imagery of people
but he would combine let's say two
numbers at a time so it could be zero
one could be two one two three seven
four it doesn't matter into an image and
then pair those together so you have
four numbers per image along locations
and this is how people memorize decks of
cards this is how people memorize 10,000
digits of pi this is how if you wanted
to if you really feel inclined I did
this in college when I was staying
neuroscience so I would wake up and
first thing in the morning I would take
the bills out of my wallet inside have
one five ten twenty whatever it might be
memorize the serial codes serial numbers
and I would tie myself then I try to
recall them forwards and backwards okay
so the benefit of this method is that
you can recall things forwards and
backwards that's why I have ABC versus
RAM all right with the loci method if
you try to memorize let's just say
foreign language vocabulary somatically
and you see many books do this and it's
because they're lazy
it's because easier to produce books
it's not because it's a better method of
learning they'll give you a thematic
vocabulary which is like animals colors
body parts
unfortunately no one communicates in
using like 50 body parts I'm it depends
on where you are maybe the armoury here
somewhere like that but the when you
memorize think systematically and a list
like that it's much like the ABCs so if
I asked you what number in the alphabet
is L you would have to count through
most people to determine what that is
it's very very slow it's not suitable
for conversational speed alright so you
need random access memory this is part
of the reason why you should you should
do two things first is if you're
memorizing let's just assume that
English is your native language if you
look at most textbooks they have foreign
language item and then English now from
left to right if if we're using the
foreign language item as our cue that
means you're only training recognition
you're not training recall so active
recall you should switch that order
number one number two particularly using
a textbook or something like that number
the items from top to bottom and then go
through let's say counting by two
counting by three from the top and the
bottom so that you have a somewhat
randomized order this is very very
important so it's also why I use visit
flashcards vis - IDI comm is the company
and they actually do the high-frequency
word list analysis so that you're
getting that 8020 from this set that
they send you so I've used that for the
last five or so languages that I've
studied speaking of imagery mix if you
if you want to amass a very high volume
of vocabulary quickly you're going to
have to use mental associations with
visual imagery almost always unless
you're like brain man which is a
fantastic documentary I'd encourage you
all check it out
yes that's synesthesia most of you
probably don't mix your senses you don't
see like smell numbers and things like
that so if we're depending on visual
imagery some images are better than
others not all images are created equal
so let's take 71 as an example 71 so we
have a few we have a few options
owls are not represented in the
in the phonetic consonant system alright
so 7-1 could be cat it could be caught
could be KITT I don't know it could be
any of them or things coated all right
why would you not want to use cut you
wouldn't want to use cut because if you
look at a picture of a cot and you ask
someone what it is they could say bed
they could say cot you will mix up your
answers you will not have accurate
recall cat cat is a cat for the most
part so you want to choose images that
have a singular label whenever possible
if not it will screw up your recall
especially if you're dealing with
several thousand characters all right
this is what I would call my personal
loom of language there's a fantastic
book also called the loom of language
very very dense so I'd suggest you start
with in other words or perhaps mind of
Annie - tis also a fantastic book on
memory aj Luria is the author so what
you're looking at here is a Japanese
comic book called one piece does anyone
here ever heard of one piece it's
usually popular hugely popular in Japan
and and now worldwide so what you're
looking at here is at the top left that
is the Japanese version of volume five
of one piece this is a very popular
manga in Japan after you come over you
see then a German version of the exact
same comic book then a Spanish version
of the exact same comic book and then an
English version at the very bottom which
is poorly translated as a side note so I
learned Japanese as my first real
foreign language I do not do any work to
maintain my languages people ask me how
do you keep your languages up I can't it
would take it would be a full-time job I
would not be able to do anything else if
I saw that as my approach to -
sustaining a certain level of fluency
there's different languages what I do
however is rather than using English to
learn each of my languages see where
this goes I learned Japanese and then
I'll pick up the German version and if I
have any missed vocabulary items or I
don't understand the grammar I will go
back to the Japanese so I'll use
Japanese to learn German
and then let's say I move on to Spanish
which is exactly what I did then I'll
use the German to learn Spanish and
going moving along in that fashion
linking each to the next I am able to
lattice this framework of language that
also gives me multiple cues for
recalling different vocabulary items
right so instead of having one English
cue for option for foreign equivalent a
I now have three or four so it increases
my accuracy it also allows me to
maintain my languages so I speak
Japanese
now just as I did when I was 15 and it's
solely from this and you can go about
doing this in a number of ways
fortunately Amazon carries a lot of
these in multiple languages you can
certainly use Google Translate for quite
a lot all the lots of extremely
time-consuming process or let's just say
in the case of Japanese you go into a
bookstore like Kinokuniya and you could
buy a travel guide or phrase book for
Italy which is also an example so this
is how I linked languages together so I
don't have to do any maintenance
whatsoever all right so the last but not
least as it relates to learning I want
to talk about the self-discipline aspect
so you can have the best method but if
you don't implement the method obviously
it's not going to work so you have to
increase not only the efficacy not only
the efficiency but the adherence are you
going to do what you actually have to do
and the way you go about doing this is
through tracking and capitalizing on
loss aversion it's more important than
the method itself all right there's a
fantastic site called stick stic KK comm
I'd recommend you check out so if you
really want to ensure that you get
something done whether that's behavioral
change related to exercise food language
learning you could take let's say 500
dollars put that down as your stake and
if you don't accomplish what you set out
to accomplish if you don't do it you
said you're going to do you have a
referee and if they say if they don't
approve or confirm that you did these
things then that 500 dollars goes off to
like the GW Bush congressional library
or
KKK or the NRA you know I'm picking my
anti charities for the bay area it's
certainly cent Tea Party whatever your
pleasure is and you make that public you
will you will learn a lot of vocabulary
trust me so the root of the rules of
behavioral change are as follows these
are really some of the more important
that make it conscious number one so if
I were to take this audience split it in
half and say all right how do you get
personal trainers randomly assigned
personal trainers you go to a gym we're
gonna give you a personal trainer you're
all trying to lose weight and then I say
all right this half we're gonna give you
iPhones we just want you to take a
photograph of everything you eat or
drink before you eat or drink it I'll
put my money on this group having more
success and more compliance and that
comes down to what has been called the
flash diet all right and before pics
making it a game I think it's very
critical here so Drucker
Peter Drucker very famous and management
theorist said what what's good what gets
measured gets managed it's unfairly
toefl what gets measured gets managed
and from Nike+ we can we can identify
that five sessions is the magic number
so if you go to five classes you go to
the gym five times you change your
breakfast five times that is when it
becomes or starts to become an ingrained
habit and so it doesn't require this
this decision-making hitpoints any
longer at that point so what that means
is you want to rig the game so that you
can win in the beginning meaning rather
than sitting down after your first five
sessions you say I need to memorize a
hundred words in this session make it
five words make it very easy to
accumulate those five sessions and have
the positive feedback from those first
five sessions making it competitive this
is the loss aversion tea party betting
etc you could just as easily put
together a wiki and betting pool with a
number of friends and then just talk an
inordinate amount of trash that's also
very very effective and I've literally
seen people you know lose gain 30 40 50
pounds doing this and it's the only
thing that will actually get them to
stick with it last but certainly not
least is
small and temporary so make it small
make it a trial if you're going to let's
say use live mocha which is a great site
for interacting with native speakers if
you don't want to or can't find one
locally make it a two-week trial five
sessions over two weeks make it
temporary anything that you foresee as
permanent or consider permanent you're
going to have terrible terrible
adherence with typical alright so
learning in some doesn't have to be very
complicated this is a sign that I have
over one of the walkways in my house
then there's a big-ass knife for
beheading people which is not related to
this lecture at all so simplify the two
are not related but so plan big but you
need to test your assumptions doing what
people consider unthinkable what people
consider impossible is very seldom such
and you need to ask the right set of
questions and one of them is what if I
did exactly the opposite of best
practices people tell me for Zetas stone
tells me that it takes a lifetime that I
need to spend $150 on there four or five
sets do I really need to do that and the
answer is no you can do what I did right
eight sentence audit go through Turkish
figure out that through a few set
phrases like Igor Nevada which is a good
day actually mean good days Vinod Hyuk
some blood okay plural you can figure
out very quickly what child and children
would be and then you walk up to rosetta
stone and you can jump to level three
and save yourself four hundred dollars
it's a lot easier than you think and
everyone here has the mental horsepower
has the capacity to do all of what I
just mentioned and far far more and very
important keep improvement relative
alright the goal is not to be the best
out of everyone the goal is to be the
best version of you possible and it
takes surprisingly little time thank you
very much
well done all right
what's sitting right here all right this
is Kevin Kelly is it not on your life
I think so Tim is such a Superman that
we are it takes two of us to ask
questions for him
and while Stuart is is sorting through
the questions that's comfortable sorry
sorted so you mentioned at one point
that your what were you were what your
goals were which was to love to be loved
and to keep learning but now it seems to
me that your serve mr. optimizer you're
kind of optimizing everything what are
you trying to optimize right now yeah
right now ha well there are a few things
I'm trying to optimize I'm looking very
specifically no big surprise at cooking
and food because I'm working on the new
project which is the 4-hour chef and I'm
not kidding actually it's totally true
and that's with that's with Amazon
publishing so they'll be launching their
New York office with that book and I
really enjoy trying to find very
nebulous or overcrowded spaces so I had
no idea how many cookbooks there are
like God so I don't yeah I didn't cook
before thinking about writing this thing
and it is the overabundance of advice is
just astonishing it's atrocious so I
love wandering into areas where there is
not too little information but a paradox
of choice as to who to follow on what to
do and then trying to simplify it
I really really enjoy that because I
think that much like in software people
are very seldom paid for removing
features it's a big problem you know
they're paid to add stuff so you end up
with this feature creep and all sorts of
problems but when it comes to skill
acquisition or up or enjoyment I think
that you can make more progress and
really appreciate more by removing
making elimination the first thing so
this thing to you one gets the
impression that you don't sleep but then
again I think oh wait
you must be optimizing how little you
sleep so what I love something like I
love it no I really do love sleeping so
if I'm doing mono phasic single block
sleep I really like to get nine hours so
for people who are like oh my god that
chemists no no I love sleep I really do
and so why aren't you trying to optimize
sleep ah because I feel like if if I
need to cut down on my sleep to get
things done that I should probably focus
on my time management first and there's
plenty of time to get the important
stuff done plenty of time for everyone
in this room to get the most important
stuff done it's just that the the
emergencies and the manufactured
important stuff which is not important
tends to encroach as soon as you resort
to let's say using email to tell you
what your calendar should look like and
that's a constant battle but when I find
myself trying to cut back on sleep I
know that there are deeper problems that
I need to fix that are unrelated to
sleep and you made your serve first
round of Fame through your book the
4-hour workweek is all the stuff you're
talking about is this work or is this
play so in the book this is a good
question the goal is not to be idle and
never was so if any of you have read the
filling the void chapter once you have
control of your time that's the
objective then you can allocate it to
where you either will have the most
impact or have the most enjoyment and
for me that's teaching I love teaching
and so I'm always going to be very very
active if it's either primarily
financially driven or I want to do less
of it I usually consider one of those
two or both to be a work
but teaching is not work to me I just I
enjoy it so much and the books and blogs
just ended up being a vehicle for that I
thought I was gonna teach ninth grade
and in high school of some time and just
I may still do that who knows but it
just turned out the accidental author
thing kind of took me in a different
direction question here from Bob Cole
pokken this relates to your make it a
game this is if you tried learning
competitive skills like chess or poker I
really need to learn that play poker I
there's so many poker parties around
here and I still can't play they're like
yeah thrown a thousand bucks a play I'm
like no no I'm that's not now we're
gonna and as much as I say maybe I
competitive it doesn't mean you want to
be a shill for people who are gonna get
a completely obliterate you I am going
to enjoy chess and one of my very close
friends is Josh Waitzkin and for people
who don't know the name if you've ever
heard of searching for Bobby Fischer the
book or the movie he's the kid I mean
the chess prodigy and an incredible
teacher so I will be getting more into
chess I really like Go positionally I
enjoy the game of Go it's very it's very
complicated not as complicated as just
but I haven't competed in those
particular games but I would like to get
better at chess Japanese chess is cool
too you can slap pieces down it's pretty
wild well you did do kick boxing didn't
he oh that's right oh yeah
sports I'm happy to compete in sports if
I feel dumb by losing something that I
don't like very much I tend to be very
poor loser so you're so kind of a long
now question from Chris do you have any
insights about slow learning over a long
period of time yeah I think that there
are there are different types of
learning and different types of
activities so when people look at me as
let's say an optimizer they assume that
it's all about achieve achieve achieve
more and less faster faster faster but
not going to speed read a novel I mean I
want to enjoy the novel
think that there are there's outcome
driven behavior and then there's process
driven behavior so if part of let's say
would working for you a big part of that
is the enjoyment of working with your
hands and you wouldn't want to rush that
as much as you like the end product so
for me I think that you can purposefully
extend how long it takes you to learn a
given skill if the process itself is in
many ways more enjoyable than then the
then the end result so for me I have no
objection to it I completely disagree
with Malcolm Gladwell's 10,000 hours I
think that that makes a fantastic sound
byte but it just doesn't stand up to
scrutiny
it depends a lot on how you define
world-class but if we're talking top 5%
with almost anything you do not need
10,000 hours if you go about it the
right way and why do you think that's an
interesting meme out there that 10,000
hours of deliberate practice is the way
to reach that where do you think that's
coming from do you think that the the
actually research is wrong do you think
that this is that the people they were
studying were actually the wrong set of
people what would you think this is
coming from I think that Malcolm's a
great writer he is a very fantastic
storyteller he's good at interviewing I
think that he's exceptionally good at
creating memes and memes benefit from
simplicity well to be fair this is not
coming from alchemy there's a there's a
set of researchers who are promoting
that first day he was reporting I think
it's very hard to gather a meaningful
data set and the best laboratory reach
person here is their own experience
which is why self-tracking is so
important but if I sat down and I
wouldn't do it to him because yes I need
to really raise the bar first but if I
were to sit down with Josh Waitzkin and
have him spent a month with me I would
have blitter eight people I'm absolutely
100% confident his teaching is that good
it's astonishing and he does it
completely differently so most people to
start with that's a opening gambit he'll
take the board put it down be like all
right King on one side pawn on the other
go I it's it's completely from the
standpoint of like standard or
traditional chess aspect
but I would not take 10,000 hours I
think that it also very much depends
however chess would probably bleed
towards 10,000 because of the number of
competitors it's just like looking at a
bell curve and weight classes and
wrestling that's good if you're if
you're 240 and you're actually pretty
good it's gonna be a hell of a lot
easier than 150 because you have fewer
people to compete against so I think it
depends a lot on the on the the actual
sport or the actual competitive playing
field as well but I haven't seen I
haven't seen any compelling data that
and even if the data said for most
people it takes 10,000 hours well for
most people they do things the wrong way
or certainly the least it's true it's
true I mean because what choice do they
have they can't become an expert in
everything so what do they do they look
at what appears to have the most
commercial success like a rosetta stone
and they go buy rosetta stone it's not
the fastest way so is there you did
crossover between the various languages
learning in German via Japanese and so
on and it's sounding like parlay you're
seeing here and this is the meta
learning story as you acquire a bunch of
skills and in the process you are
acquiring the skill of acquiring skills
and it sounds like that's pretty
rewarding it's like when the dolphin
came out she was very happy to be the 20
tricks about to do dolphin impersonation
then cut back on my caffeine sure for
you guys I suppose one of the
attractions of the 10,000 hours is I
know what I'm doing now I'm becoming an
incredible violinist and if I practice
practice practice you know I look at
Carnegie Hall this other thing is I'll
just just keep on learning how are you
finding that so far you've been at it
for what 10 years or 15 years now of you
know you learn learn learn learn learn
what happens over that sequence of
events for people like you who do that
yep so over time I get better at
acquiring skills so the meta skill
right I think if I'm applying my 10,000
hours towards anything it's bad like the
Isaac Asimov I don't know he was I think
it was Asimov who wrote like 15 million
books but at one point I remember an
interviewer asked him about one of the
subjects he'd written about and he had
no he couldn't answer they go Walt you
wrote a book about it he goes I did I've
written a lot of books and they go where
do you an expert on he goes I'm an
expert at being an expert for me the
variety is the spice of life and that
doesn't mean that I shortchange myself I
mean I I I feel like I can get to a very
high level in these various fields in a
relatively short period of time
certainly a year or less and the
incremental gains past that point are
just not appealing to it I think it's
very individual choice if you are
through god-given skill capable of
becoming the best in the world at X I
have I feel typically people know that
early on I mean if you're Tiger Woods
and your your your instead of drawing
pirate ships you're drawing trajectories
of different irons I'm not kidding I saw
this drawing it's like yeah that okay
that's not that's not normal but for
most for most people I feel like they
have the capacity to be exceptionally
good in the top 5% in the world in many
different areas but they may not have or
be able to identify the raw attributes
that are gonna push them into you know
bobsledding because they're only so many
things that you can try and and and for
me I just to try to become I could try
to become perfect in Japanese which of
course will never happen so I won't be
perfect in English or I could I could
get to the point where I can converse
like this and maybe you know 20
languages by the end of my life it's
just more appealing what kind of things
have a lasting appeal so you learn kick
boxing but I suspect you're not
kickboxing a lot right now no but some
of these other things you learned you
maybe are carrying on what kind of stuff
has that stair carrying a business
staying capacity languages somatically
languages
also that's true with sports I'm not
kickboxing anymore but I'm still
fascinated by ping pong of all things
right now but people yeah you're playing
a lot of boy you are competitive I just
know I'm just becoming fascinated by it
I haven't haven't really jumped into it
yet but there are the things that you
have tried to learn but aha we're unable
to work even with your meta yeah can you
can you sing no no I'm not confident I'm
very self-conscious about my voice and I
think the plot the primary prerequisite
for becoming good at learning skills is
being confident that you can do it and I
think part of the reason I get better at
it over time is because I'm less
intimidated by things but 10 years ago I
mean I tried to learn how to play
basketball
horrible I mean the JV coach was like
kind of look like a caveman like I might
wanna go back to wrestling it's like oh
sorry sorry and went back to wrestling
and so there's always very
self-conscious about not being able to
shoot a basketball and that is no longer
the case I'm not good but because I have
a method that I know it works and I'm
not intimidated by because I know I can
overlay that on to that skill singing do
not have the confidence so there is part
of metal learning knowing when not to
pursue something I'm you're sprinting
down to pass what are the messages that
I've done my five sessions and guess
what
this sucks yeah sure and Irish scale I
mean Gaelic Irish Irish Gaelic today how
I said would be a good example because
so few people actually use it if you
want to go hang out and spit all on the
west coast of Ireland okay you can like
hang out with some old dudes drink some
whiskey or something but that's it and
the language itself because it was
romanized it's pretty much well after
the fact there's no phonetic correlation
it's a huge pain in the ass so for me
the question is often times that how
much will I enjoy this the process the
process of learning itself how much fun
will this be
and if the answer is a lot of fun I
don't care if I retain something for a
very long period of time so that that
eight sentence audit approach that I
take I've done that for Turkish I've
done it for your Greek I've done it for
Steph for like Costa or I can't even
still can't do the clicks but I've done
it for African languages I don't
remember any of it but it improved my
travel experience it gave me such an
incredible extra-credit experience while
travelling just having 10 or 20 words it
was absolutely worth doing it at the
time but there are certainly things that
I dropped absolutely so here's a
question from Alexander Rose you were
mentioning that you like to go into a
place that's overwhelming with
information
so another overcrowded space as Xander
is parenting advice have you thought
about the for our child
sounds are there morbid doesn't it I God
my poor children it's like living a BF
Skinner or something I I feel like some
day could happen who knows but until I
actually have the experience it's easy
to talk about parenting right but until
I have like the three-year-old if storms
off and just creates complete a hell in
the grocery store I don't think that I'm
I won't be qualified to speak start with
the for our grandparents right it could
happen it could have stranger things
have happened so this is a more tactical
thing but it has the larger question
about the origins of your kind of
interest in meta learning but where did
the the eight sentence audits come from
is that something that you developed is
that something I was out there that you
just grabbed and or were is this the
larger question is about your ongoing
agenda of metal
is this something that you've sort of
always done but didn't know you were
doing it or was this a conscious thing
to start to acquire these things it
started off very random in the sense so
now it sit down and have a conversation
with someone about their language and I
would ask them how do you say this oh
well how do you say that how do you ask
this and it was whatever came to mind
and I just realized over time looking at
the responses that certain questions
yielded far more interesting answers
than others and my fantasy with language
in the in the early days was if I could
get one page some type of short story or
self introduction that would incorporate
all of the main grammatical structures
in the language all the main
conjugations and so I would know that if
I learned that page I know the language
and it became very time-consuming to do
that differently we're just not to
mention pretty unreadable but by lining
up the questions I could I could
identify the main characteristics of the
grammar which is the skeleton upon which
then you have to put everything else and
the old-fashioned traditional language
learning gets a bad rap and people are
like oh you don't have to learn grammar
you should learn kit you should learn
language the way kids learn language
which is the biggest [ __ ] nonsense
ever like you're not gonna learn like a
kid learn number one number two it's
just complete nonsense so don't buy that
you shouldn't it's slow and miserable
but the there is absolutely I think from
from a results-oriented standpoint
benefit to to addressing grammar and
that's one of the benefits that you get
when you repeatedly look at different
languages is you realize all right the
subjunctive is this it's no longer
intimidating to me it's like a
hypothetical if I had a million dollars
I would do this all right great you can
do that in Spanish you can do it in
German and all of a sudden if you have
one set of examples you can leap right
to the next very easily so so you have
phenomenal success as an author
something you've actually met a learned
about how how to engineer the the best
list but nonetheless you have a very
popular blog and lots of people who are
your students in some sense what are
they teaching you anything about how to
learn and what have you been learning
from the people trying to follow what
you've been teaching them oh I learned
more from my readers on a weekly basis
and I've taught them today easily easy
because I have particularly if I pull on
let's say Facebook a hundred thousand
plus people or on Twitter and I ask for
the best
a B or C whatever it might be I mean I
can get qualified outstanding responses
that I would not be able to find on
Google within 20 minutes so that's
information but but is it changing how
you learn is it changing oh absolutely
yeah I mean it's it's the fastest way
for me to find a shortlist of candidates
for the best of anything and so in terms
of testing if I'm gonna be testing
different methods for any number of
things cooking would be one example
running might be another example I will
crowdsource the best responses and it
absolutely changes how I approach things
but you know one of the terms that gets
thrown around my name which i think is
hysterical in the new yorker recently
like the the word guru and it bothers me
a lot the word what guru guru which
bothers makes me think of Mike Myers but
it bothers me a lot it bothers me a lot
because my objective the last thing I
want is for people to feel like they
need to come to me for answers we look
to be free answers my goal is to make
myself obsolete with every book that I
write for whatever that subject matter
is and that's that's my goal is to make
people independent learners so I I
perhaps a weird way to look at it but
this is jump up the scale there's a
question from a man Richard Lee how will
the increased rate of learning change
Society there's all kinds of stuff going
on there's what you're doing there's
Khan Academy there's
you know university courses are going
online there's a Nutella artificial
intelligence course from Stanford that's
got some thousands of people taking it
in real time as it's being taught what's
all this doing I think that the biggest
change I see is if you've lost the birth
lottery in some fashion and don't have
access to incredible schooling or peer
group whatever it might be if you're a
self-starter and you have a smartphone
which I mean billions of people will
have you have access to some of the best
instruction of the world that's very new
thing and it's very exciting we'll still
have as many dumbasses as ever probably
more than more than ever I think it'll
be look more like idiocracy than sort of
an enlightened world but the people who
are self-starters I think will have the
ability to find the quality instruction
and that's that's extremely exciting to
me sounds like you're sort of presuming
this self-starting is a talent and but I
suspect you want to make this
self-starting become a skill that and
that somebody can NAB and run with and
to some extent that's happening with
your readers because they're kind of we
had this with a Whole Earth Catalog
people gonna bump it along doing the
thing they see this thing which opens a
bunch of doorways for them yeah and they
fan out in all directions and are
grateful for that door being shown to
them they did the rest thank you so in a
sense your books in lectures and so on
have this quality I guess we're starting
to look younger and more globally
somebody to whom it has never occurred
to self start because they ever seen it
right or they're in a really really
traditional culture where self starting
is is actually you know punished mm-hmm
I'm guessing that as these things come
slipping in through the cell phones and
the other avenues that are getting to
everybody in this sense
and icing the entire world that kind of
urban sense of possibility this is the
thing you say technology does is it
opens up options for people and so I'm
getting a kind of a sense here that this
kind of learning is what is coming with
the urbanization with the acceleration
of technology and that new techniques
such as the ones you're promoting are
emerging from that whole process and are
part of it that's not a question I don't
know what I just said no I agree with
you
I would say that with with tremendous
new possibilities for learning also come
costs so the demand let's say software
there fantastic article for those of you
haven't read it Marc Andreessen wrote a
piece and I think it's why software is
eating the world on wall street journal'
fantastic piece and it points out the
tremendous opportunities that software
provides low-cost Silicon Valley
startups taking on these huge incumbents
and destroying them in effect it's it's
tremendously revolutionary but at the
same time we're gonna have tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people who are displaced and whose
set of job skills are completely
irrelevant in a world that's run by bits
and bytes so the the onus of learning I
think is as much a a responsibility and
for many people will be a curse as it is
enabling but that's that's Darwinism for
you in your own life if you noticed the
downside to your emphasis on learning as
I mean is or is there a cost that you
feel yourself
oh yeah oh absolutely I mean I've been
on the verge of nervous break that if
last five days going through these damn
cookbooks there's so much it's [ __ ] I
have like informational indigestion all
day long it's it's horrible but that's
the
but the I I think that information
overload and the overwhelm that people
feel and the apnea that they experience
when they open the inbox and they're
like yeah I think that that is a very
significant problem and you can look at
the the biochemical costs of that
obviously I've done the physical
tracking and it's very easy to correlate
the information overload with higher
cortisol screwed up glucose values I
mean there is a physical cost and I do
think that as much as people talk about
the democratization of information it's
like all right Oprah might go the way of
the dodo that's fine but you're gonna
have a thousand new Oprah's and each one
is gonna command a small army much
smaller army they'll be just as loyal
and the world I think needs and
certainly I look for curators in
different areas but I do think that the
excess of information there's always
more information than attention always
and that there are real costs and
penalties I think if you don't learn how
to single-task and firewall your
information intake so we're always
trying to encourage the speakers to take
the very long term so if we imagine this
acceleration of learning and you
accelerate it in another 100 years or
200 years what does that feel like to
you or what does it see does that seem I
mean what happens
200 years 200 years I think I have I'm
feeding on spam and I have assault
rifles and protecting a compound
somewhere no it's after Rick her as well
sends me my immortality Peck I 200 years
I don't know I I think that I think that
access to let's just say a hundred a
hundred years I I think it's the
marketing of knowledge will be very
important so the lowest common
denominator will always have more demand
then Khan Academy like I mean I saw a
headline today went all over the place
it's called was it badger eats dwarf
porn actor who resembles Gordon Ramsay
I'm not kidding and this is from and it
went everywhere and people were going
ballistic over this and if I had to sell
calculus on Khan Academy like that's
tough competition so if you want to
educate people or if they want to
educate themselves it's going to depend
on very astute people who were able to
raise the signal-to-noise ratio with the
important stuff and that's only gonna
get harder so I'll be very curious to
see how it turns out but I do think that
if you look at the silos of expertise in
different geographic areas in the world
I think it will be much more dispersed
and I think you'll have breakthrough
discoveries and developments and in many
different spaces all over the world due
to due to broadband towns smartphones
among many other things I think really
looking forward to it you will also have
very distributed sophisticated threats
biological warfare terrorism I mean
that's gonna scale at the same rate
sadly but I'm late I get between you
guys this you're both into the kind of
the quantified self the oh yeah
measuring you know
the first one behavior and body and
everything sounds up - and it sounds
like that doesn't go what you are
keeping an eye on certain things with or
you just do it while you're getting to a
goal in other words thing is how
important is this idea of measuring
things - - to your learning or do you do
critically critically important
critically critically important so for
example right now I'm traveling with a
6-inch chef's knife and under here
portable cutting yeah yeah not nuts not
carry on I've made that mistake once
already TSA does not like big knives and
I'll get let's say celery and measure it
out and get equal length sticks and test
different shopping techniques for
accuracy and speed and whatnot
oh look at this Wow man after my own our
techniques look at this I'd know when
they get Co with this it's not as sharp
as should be what are your techniques
that you're learning for example oh well
there there are I'm using also different
knives I'm looking at different up with
rocking vs. top-down versus slightly
back then forward I'm looking at chef's
knife versus santoku vs. Chinese chef's
knife vs. butcher's knife gets expensive
those damn knives they're expensive the
table is about the economy class the
idea is it is that you will time and
measure and and actually try to quantify
yeah how fast you can yeah actually for
this budget and this skill level like
this is the knife you need period end of
story
the question for Kevin and context of
this you've heard his rap and seen his
activities where does he fit in the sort
of spectrum the quantified self people
out there I think he I think Tim is
right in the middle of the quantified
self a crowd which vary from from those
who are quantifying themselves but don't
know why yeah there's a lot of there's a
lot of that to to a lot of people who
are very very specific about one thing
that they're following for a very
deliberate reason and and I think Tim is
knows why he's doing things and he's
doing a lot but are you quantifying I'm
actually not a quantifier I'm I'm I am
I'm interested in the phenomena because
I think this is a new normal
yeah I think the fact that that these
machines devices are quantifying for us
right generating data for location genes
all these implants that tim has been
experimenting with monitoring the idea
of monitoring your vitals 24 hours a day
every day instead of once a year are
going to be basically wet as normal so
I'm looking at those early adopters not
as one but as a observer just to see
where where the rest of us are going to
be going so there's more and more robots
for doing that you can have Google
Analytics tell you what you know how
your blog is doing what's actually going
on there structural level and presume I
assume in Japanese toilets now they'll
tell you all sorts of things about
yourself and they'll talk to you a very
calming with this fantastic
the you understand I lost 15 this is
like the start random present I do this
with this thing and you understand them
yeah they're great I love it but the
self-tracking will become an opt-out not
an opt-in and you see that already with
geo tagging I remember logging into
Gmail today and on my iPhone and I was
so pissed that it wouldn't let me
proceed without agreeing to Google+ for
tracking my locations like I knew it was
coming but that will become true with
physical data that would become true
with learning software if it doesn't
track you and give you feedback and tell
you where to improve and how to tweak
things they're gonna go away because
they'll be supplanted by superior
software and it will just become the new
normal and for the time being I think
the experimentation is a lot of fun and
you can actually shape that future to
something
that's right and I do think that I'm
right in the middle though you have
people who are tracking somewhat
compulsively and I do plenty of
compulsive stuff but they're tracking
something compulsively and they don't
know why then you have the people who
are tracking one thing in particular
because they have a problem with it or a
health issue and then I think right in
the middle you have people like me who
are going out to learn about something
purely out of curiosity so they'll put
an implant in and probably not do that
but you know put on a Zeo at night or
something like that and where the
phenomenon becomes really really
fascinating is when before it becomes
opt out you have groups of people let's
just say thousands of people on a site
like cure together tracking the same
thing then you can get some really
compelling data and I think that's where
clinical research has headed certainly
we'll see so in the beginning of for our
work by the way the cover the 4-hour
workweek is guy in a hammock that's not
you it seems what was that the cover of
the 4-hour workweek is there's a guy a
dynamic yeah
yeah taking these mini retirements and
so on Oh doing a lot of those I did one
just a few months ago before jumping
into looking at this new book I took
three weeks three to four weeks in
Colombia with no phone no email no
calendar that was nice so I do take my
own advice you still speak well on that
yeah yeah I'd say I travel four months a
year probably two and a half three
months or pleasure and that'll go up I
mean after this next book I'll take a
nice little break the other thing
there's a question here from anonymous
what project because they're always the
best questions who are you what project
of yours are you currently most excited
about you put that in early in the book
is you know you decide what to do and
goals and stuff like that what actually
excites you these days and what oh and
an element to it what surprises you that
it excites you cooking I hate cooking I
hated cooking much like swimming and
I've just realized it's a fantastic
vehicle and prism for learning about
food and culture and farming
and livestock and animals and the entire
animal kingdom it's really a fascinating
prism never an ancient going and no I'm
just obsessed with that so I'd say that
that's at the top of the list right now
otherwise India you wonder do television
that sounded like it was that kind of a
straightforward ambition thing or
something it excites you about it oh no
it excites me because I've seen the
power of visual medium in as a teaching
tool
I mean Khan Academy perfect example I
feel like the printed word is fantastic
and books books as they exist today
still occupy a very unique place in the
minds of readers mm-hmm that TV does not
lock you by but using whether it's
documentary or online shorts it might
not be on broadcast it could be on
YouTube it could be elsewhere but
particularly seeing the result of the
book trailer that I made for the 4-hour
body which was 60 seconds long I mean
that just blew my mind to the impact
that that had blew my mind and if that's
what I was able to do and I did this
storyboarding and hired the whole team
if I could just expand that to let's say
10 15 minutes at a time and tackle one
skill each number one I would love doing
it it'd be fun and number two I think it
would capture not only the audience that
I have already but an entirely new
audience and for me I'm just looking for
an Archimedes lever that allows me to
have the greatest positive impact that I
can during this short time that I have
so I think I think TV or something like
TV makes a lot of sense and what would
that victory success look like for you
oh there's no number like a million two
million ten million people it's just
doing having a greater impact you know
tomorrow than I did today it's just a
continual Kaizen type of improvement
thing for me I feel like that's that's
the
I can do but the the footnote out add to
that is that I don't want to simply this
is cliche but it's true I don't want to
necessarily give people you know a
painkiller the equivalent of giving the
person a fish and feeling them for a day
I would like to make as many people
independent you know critically thinking
problem solvers so they can go teach
other people that's the ideal is that
you have this cascading effect where
teachers are teaching people to be
teachers who are then teaching other
people to be teachers that would be my
ideal 1 million ten Faris's god i 1000
teachers i think that i mean i want
people to be a lot better than i am a
teacher and i think that you know that's
the only way that things get better but
we'll say let's say one one step at a
time
moving right along thank you my pleasure
thank you for having thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you